ضيوف هو عاده لا يكونون فقال في زياراتهم
لكن في الحاله التي سنتحدث عنها لا يبدو
الامر كذلك ضيف العراق اسمه كتاب اهده
سفير ايران لدى بغداد للرئيس العراقي
و 60 عدد صفحات المجلد الاول وعلى واجهته
وفي الخلفيه صورتان واحده
فيلق القدس السابق في الحرس الثوري قاسم
سليمان والاخرى للرئيس السابق حسن الشعبي
ابو مهدي المهندس قتل كلا كلاهما في غاره
امريكيه في بغداد يناير 2020
يستمرت السيطره الايرانيه على موارد
العراق والترق والوسائل عده وسنتطرق اليها
بعد قليل امتداد على نفس الخطاه خليفه
سليمان
خليفه المهندسه فالح الفياض المعاقب
امريكيا بالمناسبه
مثلا اطلق تصريحا قبل ايام
كلنا قاسم سليماني وكلنا ابو مهدي المهندس
النفطوا العراقيه جزءا من الاستراتيجيه
بالطبع ولكن لا يخفى انه نفود الايراني
على الارض بدات وزاره النفط الايرانيه
بارسال شركاتها الى العراق للانضمام للسوق
النفطيه العراقيه بعد قرار فتح مكتب
تمثيليه لها في بغداد وكان هذا موضوعنا
الاسبوع الماضي لكن الصوره تتضح شيئا
فشيئا بدخول الشركات الايرانيه للسوق
العراقيه ستتنافس مع الشركات الاجنبيه
الاخرى لكن منافسه غير متكافئه فالايران
ادواتها التي تمكنها من الحصول على عقود
التراقيس
الحشطه واحده منها قوه السلاح تسهل
الابتزاز الاقتصاديه
هدفن من اهداف طيران طبعا هنا هو الالتفاف
على العقوبات الامريكيه الاستفاده من
الاستثناء الذي تمنحه واشنطن للحكومه
لبغداد وهذا بشهاده من المسؤول للشؤون
العراقيه لدى وزاره النفط الايرانيات سيد
عباس بهشتي
المهمه واضحه تنفيذ السياسه الايرانيه
اثاره عبر الحصول على عقود التوريد وتاره
عبر السيطره على الايرادات وتره اخرى عبر
تهريب المشتقات النفسيه لكن هناك ازمه في
ما يخص النقطه الاخيره خلافا بين
المليشيات وبعضها على الحصص من المشتقات
النفطيه ففي البصره تم القبض على سته
وعشرين
المتورطا بعمليات تهريب للمشتقات النفسيه
ومنهم القيادات في ميليشيا الحشد وفي صلاح
الدين احد قال له الحشد المتورث بعمليات
تهريب وبيعه القصه مساله رائعه وكان تبدا
من رد فعلا لا يظهر الحشد بصوره الفاسد
تحت الضغط الشعبي نفذ الحشد بنفسه عمليات
اعتقال لامر اللواء وعدد كبير من معاونين
والامر جاء من القضاء ويبدو الامر لتبييض
الصوره لكن لماذا تظهر هذه الحوادث بين
الحين والاخر في الصوره الاكبر هناك خلاف
بين الميليشيا وبعضها على المناصب الامنيه
الحساسه